a new report found popular breakfast
foods and cereals marketed to children
contain a week killing chemical that
some health authorities linked to cancer
the research out this morning discovered
trace amounts of glyphosate and oats
granolas and snack bars 31 out of
forty-five tested products had levels
higher than what some scientists
consider safe for children and a
Werner's here with what these findings
mean and a good morning good morning
glyphosate is the most widely used
herbicide in the country but some
scientists doctors and activists want it
kept out of your food due to concerns
that it might cause cancer
now one environmental group finds it may
have made its way to your breakfast
table we're very concerned that
consumers are eating more glyphosate
than they know
Scott Faber has been working to improve
food safety standards for more than a
decade
he says the team at the nonprofit
environmental working group or ewg had a
lab test 45 samples of products made
with conventionally grown oats and found
glyphosate the active ingredient in the
monsanto weed killer roundup in all but
two I was shocked dr. Jennifer Lowry
heads the Council on environmental
health for the American Academy of
Pediatrics we don't know a lot about the
effects of glyphosate on children and
essentially we're just throwing it at
them AWG used its own more stringent
standards to conclude that products with
excessive levels of the herbicide
included Quaker old fashioned oats
Cheerios Quaker dinosaur egg instant
oats great value instant oats and back
to nature classic granola glyphosate was
even found in a few organic products
though most had non detectable levels
the World Health Organization says
glyphosate is a probable carcinogen the
state of California lists it as a
chemical known to the state to cause
cancer Monsanto disputes that saying in
a statement glyphosate does not cause
cancer and has a more than 40 year
history of safe use and Monsanto
criticized aw cheese research saying
even at the highest level reported an
adult would have to eat 118 pounds of
food item everyday for the rest of their
life in order to reach the epa's limit
for glyphosate residues did Monsanto
failed to adequately warned of the
potential risks answer yes but last week
a jury in California ordered Monsanto to
pay one man 289 million dollars in
damages after he claimed the company's
glyphosate weed killers caused his
cancer and aw jeez Faber is skeptical of
EPA's glyphosate limits we don't think
it does enough in particular to protect
children it is time now for them to step
up and do their jobs to ban glyphosate
Xen Honeycutt heads moms across America
a group form to raise awareness about
toxic exposures her family switched to
an organic only diet after her three
sons developed allergies and other
health problems we want to trust that
what is in the grocery store is safe and
the shocking reality is that in many
cases it's not we reached out to the
makers of those products in a statement
quaker said we proudly stand by the
safety and quality of our Quaker
products any levels of glyphosate that
may remain are significantly below any
limits of the safety standards set by
the EPA and the European Commission as
safe for human consumption and General
Mills told us our products are safe and
without question they meet regulatory
safety levels the EPA has researched
this issue and has set rules that we
follow yeah so I didn't see honey nut
cheerios or frosted flakes on the list
but what should you do should you be
looking at your cereal boxes yeah you
know it's an honor what this study sort
of seems to suggest is that the organic
products had much lower levels in
general some of them did have some
traces but that they seemed to have
lower levels of pesticides for whatever
reasons so some people may want to try
to look to see and read some of the
research themselves it's tricky though
it already didn't go organic very tricky
thank you Anna